[Music]
get all over myself
happy tuesday
so all is not well at cnn yes there's
more friction in the fake news factory
than there is between stelter's thighs
while wearing his favorite pair of
lululemons
i speak of the network home of hysterics
hall monitors and one anchor who would
make a great well anchor
as you know chris cuomo is in more hot
water than a package of ramen noodles
he just got suspended indefinitely
according to the new york attorney
general's office chris was far more
involved in his brother's damage control
efforts than previously admitted i know
a cnn anchor shading the truth
whoever heard of that
cnn got very angry fake news cnn is
totally fake
way ahead of his time now as you know
andrew cuomo the ex-governor was accused
of sexual harassment multiple times the
guy touched more women than pete
davidson at a wrap party
chris admitted to helping his brother
out in fighting the accusations and who
wouldn't help his brother really but new
documents reveal he was in regular touch
with his bros former top aide and as
accusations piled up chris demanded
knowing when damaging articles would
come out promising he'd use his media
connections to help his sleazy sibling
so this is turning into the best
lifetime movie i've ever seen
and i've seen them all
including the 12 men of christmas
delicious
now previously chris said he never made
calls to the press about his brother and
why shouldn't we believe him he's been
so honest before
all right here is the official
re-entry from the basement
cleared by cdc a little sweaty just
worked out happens
this is what i've been dreaming of
he just worked out
now to pull that off you need a blind
spot the size of wendy williams's feet
thank you
but it seems like chris was indeed
gathering intel including dirt on one
accuser you know hillary would be so
proud of chris
after hearing all this i'd wonder how
does chris keep his job but then i
remember this guy
drew that was an unintentional error and
everyone deserves forgiveness for honest
mistakes but greg even if that involves
burping the worm during a network zoom
call
well i go back and forth on this much
like tubin
but my point is this it's natural for
network competitors to enjoy the
spectacle of a rival's implosion it's
like when they demolish an old hotel in
vegas you'll love to watch it and cuomo
kind of deserves it he's a blowhard who
lauded antifa and smeared decent focused
bigots he churns out fake news like the
amish do butter telling you to live by
the rules that he then happily pisses on
like a urinal cake
he screamed at you to obey lockdowns as
he violated his own seriously what a
list of obnoxiousness to choose from
it's like the polyester shirt section at
walmart
there's q-tip theater where chris stole
one of carrot top's props to humanize
his jerkface brother
in scale
this was the actual swab that was being
used to fit up that double barrel
shotgun that you have mounted on the
front of your pretty face
you know maybe he was just trying to
keep his brother's nose clean
there's the moment where he mocked the
crime wave and those who were raising
alarms about it they're gonna take your
country away and they're taking down the
statues and crime is rising
oh my gosh it's so bad and again
defunding police it's like
yeah that didn't age well by the way
it's nice to see chris finally discuss
the new smash and grab robberies smash
and grab it sounds like one of his
brother's top dating techniques
but i guess chris could no longer chalk
that violence up to show me in the
constitution where it says looting has
to be peaceful he also defended antifa
antifa or whomever anarchist or
malcontent or misguided they are also
wrong to hit but fighting hate
is right and in a clash between hate and
those who oppose it those who oppose it
are on the side of right
he was in short an overpaid jackass
but in the media that describes all of
us except of course killmead he's just a
jackass
anyway but i feel at times that i'm an
overpaid jackass too but then i remember
i work at fox and i conclude that i am
an underpaid jackass
seriously fox how can you expect me to
maintain a bolivian cocaine habit six
mistresses three full-time cabana boys
and saint barts on a 14 mil a year
salary
it's like they don't even consider the
fact that my shoe inserts are made of
ivory
last week i had to let a house boy go
because this non-stop crying upset my
bengal tigers
so what am i getting at the scuttlebutt
in this high school cafeteria called the
media is that chris is what you find
next to your ham and eggs at ihop toast
well it's either toast or a lee press-on
nail
but he's like the greeks ancient history
he's like peaches at the supermarket
canned he's like a loaded gun on an alec
baldwin set
discharged
but why should he be fired what did he
do wrong i mean besides helped a corrupt
politician smear an accuser by using his
network connections that's it come on
who hasn't done that before am i right
i say it's not time to fire chris but to
save him
right now america's hero is under fire
his name chris cuomo his only crime
helping his brother and also uncovering
dirt on a sexual harassment victim using
his media connections
but is that really grounds for dismissal
we say no
here's why
if they fire chris they might replace
him with someone better like this guy
or this guy or this guy
thankfully it'll never be this guy
plus america needs chris cuomo not for
the news facts or educated opinions for
the laughs tell me where it says that
protests are supposed to be polite and
peaceful but the turnout of white
supremacists was thankfully pathetic
which is why i didn't have to go there
and go this is a travisha mockery a
travesty of a sham of a mockery for pure
knucklehead entertainment you couldn't
beat chris with a bag of dead crickets
oh the crunch
that's good eating and finally we don't
root for people being fired even if they
root for us to be fired unless it's
joyride she's a racist
so it's time to save chris cuomo and
save america let's get out let's get
after it let's get out let's get out
let's get after it let's get after
for a lack of a better term i can't quit
chris
and look the media is a moronic medium
so it is his fault that he's a [ __ ] we
attract him like flies on poop and it's
this environment that often dictates
changes in your behavior i mean look at
cat
she wasn't this
crazy when i met her
the news did it to her this was her
before fox
[Laughter]
and you've seen it yourself so and so
leaves fox for some place else and
suddenly they're different
so the old line is don't hate the player
hate the game i came up with that as a
kid while playing spin the bottle with
my grandmother schnauzer
the [ __ ]
but the game these days is to inflame
divide and in sight until we change that
game there will always be more chris
cuomo's than greg gutfeld's firing them
does no good because another one bubbles
up if we keep at it who knows we'll be
hosting who will be hosting that cnn 9pm
slot
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guest
he's up at the crack of dawn spreading
news without a yawn co-host and fox and
friends first host bob pyro i said host
twice
she's worked in more places than wd-40
fox business anchor susan lee
she gives drug sniffing dogs a contact
high [ __ ] his contributor cat tim
and he lights his cigars on the sun
my massive sidekick in the nwa world
television champion tyrus
susan as we were going to the show we
found out on twitter that mr cuomo was
indeed indefinitely suspended i want him
to stay what do you think is going to
happen i want him to stay it's i'm like
the harlem globetrotters i want to play
the washington generals every day
and you cheer for the underdogs i get it
uh no i'm the over dog oh yeah i cheer
for the overdogs
yeah i want to crush the underdog don't
judge the stance
look i think this is a great case study
though to once you open pandora's box
and you go down that rabbit hole you
can't come out of it so he can't be both
brother and broadcaster i think the
atlantic said it best did you read the
atlantic today i was surprised by that
no the magazine who reached magazines
i read it i did read it publication and
it said he failed his viewers he's
broken his journalistic integrity and he
has to go wow so you think you should go
all right well well i mean he did he did
some bad if he was hounding an accuser
or using his uh professional ties to go
after an accuser that's wrong but still
todd that's not about me this is about
me it's all about you
if if i lose chris cuomo todd that's
four segments on this show that i don't
get
we're just gonna have to read your book
literally live readings on air of your
book but if you haven't purchased it yet
todd i suggest you do i love the plug
but i keep asking myself why have they
kept this guy around so long it's not
like he's delivering these massive
ratings i was telling you before my show
is on at 5 00 a.m i'm awake for only
half of these shows some days we beat
chris cuomo's show
in the all-important thank you thank you
way to plug my show yeah what demo is it
it's the meth head demo yes yes it is
huge
huge but that's the point if you have
such a cancer like this in your locker
room and that's the cnn locker room
don't you get rid of him to improve the
overall product but cnn doesn't you saw
tubing you've seen other people they
just don't care my theory is is that
it's a clip factory cat they don't care
about the ratings they care about
putting out sensational clips that then
travel along the internet like demons in
the night to destroy you
that's a that's an interesting theory i
have many more theories sometimes i
write them down i know that
i know that look yeah i mean i don't
think they had a choice i don't think
that they wanted to get rid of him i
think they tried really really hard to
not get rid of him i mean not just that
montage but i mean he obviously was
helping more than he said right we all
knew that and like we know what he said
my favorite texts in terms of showing
why he's the worst is he's like oh if
all they have is lindsay then that's a
good sign yes
he's saying that he knows there's a lot
worse stuff he wasn't like oh of course
that's all they have because my brother
would never do these things right he
wasn't defending his brother because he
thought like oh he would never do this
he was defending his brother because
they're they're both bad dudes well also
but they are brothers and i'm surprised
he hasn't used the we weird italian
defense which is brother used which
should ban you from italy
i think all right tyrus we're italian
yes we're italian that's what we do
that's what his brother said but i
digress here's the thing you're an
athlete like should you take pleasure
like i i actually look at this and i
think you know he should go but at the
same time it's like i'm not i don't like
rooting for people to lose their jobs
unless it's joy reid because she's a
racist so are you saying like do i take
great joy in crushing my enemies or
opponents yes within the confines of the
game yes do i follow him afterwards in
the parking lot and drag him no
there's a lot of unpacking in your
monologue i'm still trying to figure out
what the hell burped the worm means but
whatever um i don't want to know and
please do not continue
but i agree with you greg i don't think
that he should be fired until they have
their investigation
we have two we're not let's not be like
them right
they'll make an allegation against the
guy and not even do the due process and
he's fired and then you find out later
on although their evidence is damning in
terms of what he was doing with his
brother with the text message and stuff
but he's also got a sexual harassment
allegation on him too but hasn't got an
investigation so we should wait in the
meantime we'll enjoy his dumbassery yeah
and then if it's found in the
investigation that he did do the things
he's accused of then yeah you got to
fire him but until that point they
shouldn't just do the woke thing and
ruin a guy's life until you can prove it
that's just fair
uh you have what you have swayed the
audience in your favor how does this
that you're the you're the quote
business expert susan actually my
favorite text in that exchange was when
he said i got a lead on the wedding girl
yeah i mean what what is that
investigation what is the wedding girl
nothing in any context no matter what no
way to make that a good thing yo saw the
wedding girl
[Laughter]
it might be an independent an
independent film opening at sundance and
he was getting tickets oh i have a lead
on the wedding girl it's a charming film
fable yes what does this do to cnn does
it does it destroy the network say yes
so it might surprise you i've worked at
other places besides here like wd-40
and as todd would know that i think in
any other place you would be fired yeah
there you go well we're going to be
covering this wall-to-wall
for the rest of my life
what are they going to do with the
double box with him and don levinson
they have the i love you session before
oh do they do that you know do you you
should totally zoom in
yes you know what the thing is stelter's
sitting there at least he's like he's
he's he's
like hovering over a canned ham right
now he's like this is mine you notice he
didn't really defend he was the first
guy to tweet it out he's been speaking
outside his office
he's been he's been waiting i'm gonna
have to let out cuomo's pants he keeps
just walking by i cannot get into this
just walking by
exactly hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else